[Musica]
c'era una volta un capo
la sua azienda era un'azienda
fantastica faceva dei prodotti
eccezionali producevano in maniera
tirato una lim perfettamente tirata
funzionava tutto benissimo i clienti
erano soddisfatti la qualità eccezionale
funzionava tutto benissimo
questo capo aveva solo un grande cruccio
vedeva le persone che lavoravano con lui
le guardava le guardava lavorare le
guardava mettersi d'impegno sforzarsi
per creare un'azienda per creare un
prodotto eccellente perché non è un
prodotto con quella qualità che lui
desiderava
però
vedeva che potevano dare di più
vedeva che non erano davvero
responsabili come lui si sarebbe
aspettato non erano davvero autonomi
come lui avrebbe voluto
vedeva che non erano produttivi nel
risolvere i problemi dell'azienda non
erano motivati come lo era lui che ogni
mattina si svegliava per primo e
arrivava
puliva tutto quelle cose che vedeva
ancora in disordine alla fine la sera
era l'ultimo ad andarsene
ogni giorno questo capo arrivava in
azienda
e si chiedeva perché
perché i miei collaboratori non sono
così motivati perché perché
io mi metto così tanto di impegno perché
io faccio così tanto per loro e loro non
fanno altrettanto per me vogliono solo i
soldi
ma io gli do un lavoro io gli do un
sogno a cui ambire io gli do un prodotto
eccellente di un'azienda bella dove
stare dove vivere perché
perché non sono così motivati
perché non sono
responsabili come io vorrei
ogni giorno se lo chiedeva e più se lo
chiedeva e più capiva che forse la
domanda era quella sbagliata
e allora un giorno iniziò a chiedersi
come posso io
fare in modo
che loro siano come io li vorrei
come posso renda di persone responsabili
composto motivarli spronarli come posso
renderli autonomi veramente nel fare il
loro lavoro come posso renderli
proattivi nel risolvere i problemi che
ci sono perché ci sono sempre dei
problemi ci sono sempre dei margini
miglioramento nessuno è perfetto
e questo è un capo intelligente non
erano un idiota era uno che lo sapeva
che aveva margine di miglioramento
cos'è il mio potere fare
per ottenere questo risultato
potere potevamo parola buffa
il capo sa di avere il potere
il potere di prendere decisioni
il potere di influenzare la vita dei
suoi collaboratori
ma davvero ma qual è il potere del capo
lo siete mai chiesti qual è davvero il
potere di un capo quando a che fare con
i suoi collaboratori
io negli ultimi 5 anni circa
ho studiato in maniera approfondita il
modo in cui funziona questa relazione
speciale che quella che leda che lega un
leader quei suoi collaboratori
e ho trovato che ci sono quattro
strategie
quattro azioni 4 comportamenti che tutti
i capi mettono in pratica quando
esercitano il loro potere
ciò che fa la differenza è come li
mettono in pratica
il primo la conoscete tutti la delega
ok capo deve delegare ok l'avete letto
su tutti i libri l'avete sentito dire in
tutte le salse un capo deve delegare ok
ma come delega un capo
molto spesso quando siamo in azienda si
trova la delega la cosiddetta delega per
mansioni no tu sei la persona che è
responsabile di passare i prodotti sulla
cassa quando passa qualcuno pagare tu
sei la persona che deve spostare questo
pezzo da qui a qui tu sei quella persona
che deve lavorare la fresa
che deve gestire la contabilità
che deve stare sui social
questa la delega come viene normalmente
interpretata no ma c'è un altro modo per
delegare che quello per obiettivi ora
delle gare per obiettivi significa
assegnare alle persone un obiettivo da
raggiungere un risultato da portare
secondo voi chi
ogni giorno vive la sua delega per
mansioni
e compie sempre la stessa azione
ripetuta in maniera quasi alienante sarà
motivato
sarà responsabile di colazione si
sentirà partecipe
proattivo nel voler risolvere i problemi
a come mi piace questa parola no
sento già i capi che la pensano sì
perché una volta che ho delegato li devo
controllare i collaboratori
ma cosa vuol dire controllare di nuovo
beh se dall eco per mansioni di costarle
a guardarli e questo è l'unico modo che
c'è per essere sicuri che davvero
facciano ciò che io gli chiedo di fare
ma se delego per obiettivi
cosa controllo controlli risultati
controllo che effettivamente il lavoro
sia svolto con il livello di qualità che
mi aspetto controllo che l'output del
processo
sia quello da attese i tempi siano
rispettati
sono ad un livello più alto sono ad un
livello diverso
e di nuovo pensate a voi stessi
pensate quando eravate piccoli
andavate a scuola portavate a casa
magari un brutto voto
e magari i vostri genitori li mettevano
in punizione che vi dicevano no ma
adesso ti controllo controllo come studi
controllo quanto studi controllo che tu
sia davvero lì a leggere il libro e non
a fare altro a uscire con gli amici
giocare con la playstation quello che
volete
e motivante questa roba qua e sentite
responsabili quando qualcuno mi
controlla in questo modo
quando qualcuno vi sta con il fiato sul
collo per vedere per controllare che
stiate facendo le cose giuste
naturalmente alla fine c'è la correzione
nell'azienda lo sappiamo bene correzione
vuol dire cazziato farina con cazziatone
per dirla in termini un po più eleganti
si usa parlare di carota e bastone noti
premio quando fai le cose giuste ti do
una punizione
quando fai le cose sbagliate non sapete
come si dice no che se si usa carota e
bastone si lavora con gli asini non con
gli esseri umani
qual è il modo giusto di correggere se
si vogliono ottenere collaboratori
responsabili
autonomi
motivati
quand'è che voi
crescete vi sentite responsabili
autonomi e motivati quando qualcuno vi
guida a capire dove sbagliate a capire
come correggere gli errori che avete
commesso
a capire come sviluppare le vostre
competenze
il punto della correzione non è fare la
punizione non è fare il cacciatore non è
fargliela pagare a quello che ha
commesso un errore
e aiutarlo a comprendere l'entità
dell'errore come correggerlo come
risolverlo e come evitare di commetterlo
di nuovo
e che poi ci porta al grande paradosso
perché pensateci un attimo
io vi sto raccontando di un capo che
delega per obiettivi e per obiettivi che
sono sempre più ampi che controlla sui
risultati e controlla sempre meno perché
più l'obiettivo e l'altro o meno ho
bisogno di controllo è ampio meno
bisogno di controllare
che corregge con l'obiettivo di rendere
ancora più autonomi
sto parlando di un capo inutile di un
capo che si rende inutile per il suo
team
per che più mette le persone in
condizione di essere responsabili
autonome proattive motivate più si rende
inutile
inutile ma essenziale perché il suo
ruolo è quello di abilitare le persone
del suo team
essere ciò che vuole che siano essere
responsabili ad avere performance
eccellenti essere motivate
e quindi io vi invito
a riflettere su questo tema
vi invito a farvi venire il dubbio che
tutto ciò che pensate di sapere sulla
leadership e sul management
in realtà sesso un retaggio di un'altra
epoca
perché il vero potere di cui abbiamo
parlato prima
e quello di abilitare gli altri ad
esercitare il loro potere
perché alla fine nelle nostre aziende
perché siano veramente migliori perché
siano eccellenti
c'è bisogno di capi inutili
il mondo ha bisogno di più capi utili
[Applauso]